um because a lot of times we'll kind of
go to personal attacks or we'll go to
well not all women are like that or
whatever but I think the first response
has to be is it true and that's kind of
the red pill that I really had was I
just realized that the things they were
saying were true I didn't like some of
them
I didn't think some of them applied to
me but you know at the end of the day if
it doesn't apply Let it Fly and
if we're at a point in society I'm
walking around Vegas I can't tell the
difference between wives and mothers and
hookers they dress the same nowadays we
kind of have to look in the mirror and
say well this isn't a great direction
that us as a group are going